[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE OVERSTROM: Hey, everyone.
My name is Dave Overstrom
from the Google Maps team.
I'm down here in
lovely Atlanta, Georgia
with the Weather Channel for
the Code the Road Hackathon.
CROWD: Storm the Road!
Whoo!
CHRIS HUFF: Right
now, developers
are hacking upstairs, coming
up with innovative ideas
around safety and preparedness.
CAMERON CLAYTON: As
you're presenting,
always remember, what's
the problem in the market?
And then how does my
solution solve that problem?
MALE SPEAKER: We're trying to go
from idea to an actual runnable
app in 24 hours.
It's a pretty hard challenge.
MALE SPEAKER: I expect it to
probably get kind of crazy.
CROWD: Aaron, Aaron!
[CHEERS]
BRYCE: Hey, my name is Bryce.
I just won the rock,
paper, scissors contest
at the Weather
Channel Hackathon.
Puts you in a
unique environment.
You're just in some random
room with a bunch of people
you don't know,
and you're supposed
to come up with something.
It's cool.
MALE SPEAKER: I wrote a whole
bunch of code, and none of it
made it into the project.
JAMES MCGILL: Watching
those presentations,
I would have bet any amount
of money that you had not,
in fact, stayed up
for nearly 24 hours.
MALE SPEAKER: Third place, EDS.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: My
team was working
on an Android mobile app that
helps with emergency delivery
services.
MALE SPEAKER: Second
place, Watchtower.
MALE SPEAKER: When you
go somewhere abroad,
language is a barrier.
And that was really our
goal, to connect people
with the people who could
be the most help to them.
MALE SPEAKER: First
place, Beforecast.
MALE SPEAKER: We built pretty
much a calendar application.
When you made an appointment,
it would tell you the weather.
So if you wanted
to go on a picnic,
you would know if
it's going to rain.
JAMES MCGILL: Getting to
judge these applications
and participate in this
event was worth every hour
of sleep I didn't
get last night.
Everyone, pat on the back,
congratulations, and well done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]